- I don't think competency
is the driving factor,
but I see the calculation
a little differently.
I think that what we
need is the person
who can get elected, right?
Like, if you want Joe
Biden out, and I do,
I've been open about it
for the reasons I stated,
you have to go with whoever
is most likely to do that.
And I know that Nikki Haley's
supporters think it's her
and Ron DeSantis
supporters think it's him.
But my calculation is somebody
who would take any
of those guys or gals
is you gotta get the one who,
who can bring together
the, the biggest coalition.
And the Trump coalition
is never leaving Trump.
They're just not
going to leave him.
So I think the rest
of the coalition
is probably going to
migrate over to them
because they're immovable.
I just see that
as their reality.
So eventually the rest,
they're just gonna have to bend
to the Trump coalition's will,
because the Trump
voters are not gettable
that some 25 to
35%, depending on,
you know, who you believe,
they're just never gonna move.
And the Republicans need to win.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin.
This is "The Rubin Report".
And you know what?
This woman just does not
need an introduction.
Megyn Kelly, my
friend, and an actual,
I'm gonna consider
you a journalist.
I'm not sure that's what you
consider yourself anymore.
Hello, how are you, my friend?
- Hi, I'm good.
How you doing, Dave?
- I'm all right, I'm all right.
I think it's actually
perfectly fitting to have you
on the show this week.
We were supposed to do
this a couple weeks ago,
and then I think both our
schedules went a little wacky.
But to have you on today,
obviously right in the middle
of this Israel Hamas thing.
And just sort of really what
I wanna focus on, I guess,
and then we can, you know me,
we can talk about whatever
you wanna talk about,
is sort of like the
media reaction to this
and how we're seeing like a
new type of war unfold online.
And if it wasn't for Twitter
right now, and, you know,
if it was the old days for you
back at your
corporate job at Fox,
how maybe you'd have
to cover it differently
or even at NBC
during that stint.
So maybe kind of take it from
there, like, well, first off,
what do you make of
the last couple days,
just kind of broadly,
and then we'll kind
of try to narrow it.
- You know, it reminds
me of like 2015,
I think that's the right year.
When Isis was getting really
aggressive in the Middle East.
And you'd go on the air and
at night and ask yourself,
can I repeat any of this?
Can I show any of this video?
This is so beyond the
pale, it's so evil.
We're not gonna show them
burning people alive in cages.
We're just not gonna do that.
And there were certain lines
that you wouldn't cross
as a news organization,
you know, on cable.
And I'm having that
same feeling now,
like can you show the absolute
rape and murder and torture
of human beings in Israel?
Can you, should we?
And I've been watching
my friends in the media
make their own decisions
in our digital lane,
which has different rules now.
You know, you do
have more freedom
if you make the editorial
choice to show it.
And we've been
debating it internally.
It's, we can show it.
It's just, there's only so
much the human heart can take.
- Mm-hmm.
- You know.
There's, I don't
know, I'm sure you,
because I know you've got
people you love there,
but even I, as somebody
who's got more distance
between me and Israel
and the actual events,
but just a supporter of Israel
have been walking around
with just such a heavy heart
over the past few days.
It's affecting everything.
It's affecting the way I'm
interacting with my family,
with my friends, you
know, my sleeping.
- Yeah.
- That's with all the distance
in the world between
me and the events.
Every inch closer
and it's even harder.
So at some point,
I do think over here
we've been showing
some of the tapes not all.
You know, you have
to make a decision
to protect yourself
and your wellbeing
and be able to report
on it, you know,
without feeling the
heaviness of it.
Otherwise you can't
get through it.
You saw that reporter, the
Israeli reporter today,
trying to report, you know,
as a professional on the babies.
- Mm-hmm.
- You know, a phrase, I don't,
I don't know if any it's
ever been uttered before
in the, in news coverage
anywhere, decapitated babies.
I don't know if anybody had ever
even considered that horror.
And then you find 40,
like how do you go
on with your life?
How do you do anything
other than take up arms
against these people?
And so I fully understand
what I'm seeing online
with people saying,
Gaza must be raised.
That's it.
- Mm-hmm.
- There should be
no more Gaza.
It should look
like a parking lot
when Israel is done with it.
That is how I feel too.
And the only thing that would
dissuade me from that feeling
is if it's going to lead to
more destruction for Israel
and her allies.
You know, if it's going to
provoke Iran or Hezbollah
even more and cause more
headaches for Israel.
Because that to me seems
like the only quote
proportionate response
to what's being done.
- Yeah, proportionate,
I've really come
to hate that word.
It's a disproportionate
response.
It's, oh, so you murdered,
and raped, and burned,
and beheaded our children and
our women and everything else.
Let's say a thousand.
Could we get a
thousand of your people
so we can proportionately
do those same things?
I mean, how much of this,
now that you're on this side,
on the media side,
where you fully,
I know that everything, well,
even when you were on Fox,
I know you personally,
so I know everything
was coming out
of you Megyn Kelly, yourself,
and you were saying
what you believed,
but now in the total freedom
to do this the way you want
and have those conversations
with your guys about
how much of this can we show
and how much can I deal
with and everything else.
How different is that than maybe
when you were in the
corporate side of things?
- I mean, I will say
that when I was at Fox,
they were very pro-Israel,
and they were never hesitant
to show what was being done
to Israel by its
enemies, Hamas included.
So I never felt
constrained there.
And certainly when ISIS was
enacting its atrocities,
we didn't show everything.
It was just, again,
it's just too much.
And there are rules on cable.
But we showed a lot.
And we didn't go easy on them.
At NBC, I was lucky
enough not to have
this kind of thing pop up in
my very limited time there,
nor would they be,
have been expecting the
9:00 AM show to do it.
So I wasn't forced into this
kind of decision making.
So I think that's
fortunate for me.
I'm seeing it more right now
with the mainstream media
and the choices they're making,
the editorial choices
they're making.
- Yeah.
- They're going and have
gone exactly the same way
that we saw them go during BLM,
during these other, you know,
massive conflicts
that have divided us.
And this just shouldn't be one.
This just shouldn't be one.
This should just be like,
there's a reason Joe Biden
sounds for the most part,
like you and me right now.
- I know, it was shocking.
- Right, there's
very few things.
- It was shocking.
- Right, where we were all-
- It was right before
we're taping this. Yeah.
- Yeah, where we would
all sound the same.
Now we can talk
about his remarks.
And I don't think he
went far enough, but he,
his core message was a good one.
And I agreed with
what he was saying.
What's happening, where
you and Mark Levin and I,
and the guy who runs,
you know, the ADL,
the Greenblatt guy,
all agree but the,
the Washington Post
and Forbes and all the
college campus groups
are saying something
very different.
It's like the media and the
academy that's been co-opted
by the wokest of the woke.
And as we've known
for some time,
that doesn't include Jews.
It doesn't include
Jewish people.
As Bari Weis once put it to me,
we don't rate, we don't count.
We're not on the list
of protected classes,
even though we are
technically a protected class.
- Right, well, you can't have
a minority that succeeds.
It breaks the entire
intersectional calculator.
They like their minorities on
their knees basically forever.
I mean, that, that's
kind of how it works.
Coming from, I just wanna hit
the mainstream media thing
one more time,'
cause I think we're,
I actually think that this
moment is like, to me,
it's actually causing
a massive shift.
Almost the final shift
in what we needed,
where the mainstream media
will not be relevant anymore
and the online will be.
But I'm also a little
concerned because, you know,
there's an awful lot of
people who talk for a living
that have no idea what
they're talking about,
and know nothing about history
and have huge audiences
and confuse people either
intentionally or not.
What do you think
we do about that?
Like, we can do the,
we can bash mainstream media
all day long and this or that,
but what do we do about this
other thing where it's like,
you're pretty damn good and
you're on the short list
of people I trust
and I guess a couple
people like me,
but like, we're not perfect.
And now people are going to
anybody that has a webcam,
which is basically everybody.
- Well, and on, you know, X
formerly known as Twitter,
it's a similar problem in that
now that it's been monetized
and you get more money if
you've signed up for that,
which I haven't,
you get more money if
you get more engagement.
So it's in your interest
to just be as provocative-
- Yeah.
- As possible.
And you line your
pockets that way.
So that's problematic.
I mean, I'm a capitalist.
I'm not against people
making money, but I,
the system is set
up in a fraught way.
And you could argue
the same is true large.
You know, cable news
does better if it bleeds,
it leads that kind of thing.
And so you have to find,
ideally somebody who, I mean,
you've done very well,
I've done very well.
I don't need this paycheck
in order to survive.
I need my integrity
to look at myself
in the mirror every morning.
So you have to find
a person like that.
It doesn't have to be me or you,
but you have to figure
out whether this person's
there for dollars or whether
they're an honest broker.
And whether they tell you the
things you don't want to hear,
even when it hurts,
what you know is the anchor
or the host's side, right?
That's how I would
make my decision.
But on something this complex,
you really do need to be choosy
about where you get your info.
I mean, most of these
anchors on CNN or MSNBC
forget that are, you know,
a bunch of twits who have
absolutely no education
on any of this stuff.
- Yeah.
- And are too lazy
to do their homework.
They wanna be stars, Dave.
They don't wanna
actually be your guide
through something as complex
as the Israeli-Palestinian
relationship.
They don't wanna do a deep
dive on Hamas and Gaza
and what happened in
2005 and what happened,
you know, who started
bombing who first and why,
and why the blockade
was put into play.
They don't care.
They want what gets them clicks.
And what gets you cliques
amongst the young people today
is to say that Israel
is a colonializer
and that they're the oppressor
and that you're on the
side of the oppressed
'cause that's what's hip today.
You're BLMer and
they're oppressed,
and you're on the side
of the LGBTQ people
'cause they're the oppressors,
they're not aggressors.
And therefore you're on the side
of the Palestinian slash Hamas,
the poor Hamas oppressed people
who live in the new term,
quote, an open air prison.
- Gays for Palestine
is very different
than Palestine for gays,
that's what I always
tell everybody.
It's like, it's like,
come on, come on.
- Just a simple Google search
would help you out so much
before these idiotic
posts young people.
- Yeah, God.
Does it seem to
you in a way that,
that the reason we got to
this moment was not just,
well, putting aside like there
are genocidal organizations
and there's hate and
like that kind of stuff,
but this moment now where
we're at with media and where
we're at with confusing
children about their gender
and where we're at
with open borders,
like all of the stuff
that this was obviously
going to be where we were
gonna get to at some point.
Like that's what I've been
feeling the last couple days.
Like suddenly it's here,
it feels like
something new is here.
And I've sort of
been just like, oh,
of course we were
going to get here.
What did you think?
You know, when I see the
Hamas rallies in New York
in Times Square, it's
like, well, of course
that was going to happen
if you have open borders
and you don't defend your
culture and all of those things,
and maybe that makes me sound
like crazy right wing Mark
Levin now, but here we are.
That's obviously sarcasm.
- No, and it's a good point.
I've been thinking about,
I had to go through
my phone recently
and I had to find
this old picture
of my now 14 year old
son, like a baby picture.
So it required me
to scroll through
what you're going
through right now, right.
All the fun baby videos.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And on there was a
video of my daughter
who was six when
Trump was elected.
And my daughter at the
time did not like Trump
because as she put in her
little video, he bullied my mom.
That's how she, she was six.
- I think I always said to you,
you get like a full pass
and I'll grant that pass
to your daughter as well.
- So she's come around.
- That's funny, that's funny.
- But at the time,
she was not his fan.
- Yeah.
- And she was saying
in this little piece, he
shouldn't be president.
Can you change presidents?
Right, and so she
wasn't his fan.
And honestly for some
reason that like every time
I look at Joe Biden,
that is what I think right
now, he shouldn't be president.
Can you change presidents?
Like how soon could we get
Donald Trump, Ron DeSantis,
Nicki Haley, Vivek Ramaswamy?
I don't give a damn.
- Yeah.
- Any of them.
- How soon can we
get them in there?
Because you can
feel us losing it,
like all of it by the second.
You know, like you say from
the very simple premise
that we don't hurt our children.
We don't voluntarily
allow our children
to cut off body parts
and sterilize themselves
and become essentially
asexual when they're 15
because they're going
through a phase.
We don't, we don't do that.
That's something only
lunatics would do.
And we certainly protect
our border to the point
where we don't have cities
overrun with migrants.
And like New York, where
you have to get a translator
for every single language
that appears in your
publicly funded school
where you've paid your
taxes and they haven't.
And now your kid's gotta
wait and a line for an hour
to enter the classroom,
where then he will,
he will be told about sexuality
and ask whether
he really is a she
and given a book about blow
jobs that you only wanted
to get through the third
grade without reading.
But that's our country.
And then you walk
out in a Times Square
from this public city school
and you see babies having
been beheaded in Israel,
and the next thing you
see is some group chanting
like gas the gaze or gas
the Jews, it's the same.
I don't know, who knows?
Right, you get what, wait, what?
Right, so it's very jarring.
And you and I have
something in common,
which if you try to
maintain our sense of humor.
- Yeah.
- This has been critical
to staying a well person
and staying, I think, in
this lane that we're in
and still wanting, having
people wanna listen to us
because it can't be
all dark and awfulness.
And in these moments,
it's very hard to laugh.
- You know, when you,
you came and you did the,
on my book tour, you did
the show in West Nyak,
which was one of the best
nights of the entire tour
because it was you and it
was the one New York show,
which was my home.
I once lived in New York
before I lived in the
free state of Florida.
And you describe me on
stage as a happy warrior.
And I guess I never really
thought of myself that way,
but I think that I ultimately
am, and I have to say,
in doing my show this week, I,
this is the hardest it
has ever been in my life.
I mean, literally on Monday,
I walked out of the studio
and I cried, like, what?
Do you ever find that?
Like how do, how did
it be that Megyn Kelly
ended up being one of the people
that is gonna make sense
of the world in a time
where no one's making any sense?
Like, for you deep, like
personally, how it became you?
- I mean, it's very hard.
These day and weeks
are very, very hard.
But I do think it's important
to not forget your humanity.
I know I told this
story in my book
and I told it for a reason,
but there was a moment after,
on 9/11 where on "Good
Morning America",
it was Diane Sawyer and
Charlie Gibson anchoring.
And as the tower went down,
the first tower went down,
Charlie Gibson had the
glasses at the end of the nose
and was the network anchor
and just continued reporting.
The tower appears to
have fallen, you know,
the number of the loss of
life will be significant.
And, Diane Sawyer
said, "Oh my God."
And it was a lesson, you know.
He regretted his response
and wished it had
been more like hers.
She didn't forget her
humanity in the moment.
She did go on to
report all those things
that he was saying and
maintained her professionalism.
But in these moments,
it's okay to still
be a human being.
And I actually
think it's important
to still be a human being.
Like yesterday,
we opened the show
with a description of
what the latest was,
you know, the horrors
out of Israel.
And I'll just tell you the
truth, after the show was over,
we always do like a, you know,
a post-game meeting
with the team.
And I was critical of the
way we set up the show
because we did this very tug
at your heartstrings intro,
all of which was true
and real and proper.
And then we went, went right
to Ted Cruz, who I like.
But what Ted Cruz really wanted
to talk about was politics
and the Biden administration,
all of which was good.
But what we needed was a
moment to sigh and think
and reflect and talk
about how we were feeling.
Just a minute.
You don't have to spend an
hour, but just a minute,
instead of getting
right to the hard,
the hardness of it all.
And I do think those
moments are what help us
remain happy warriors, Dave.
You know, it's like you
can't go right to anger
on any of these stories.
You do have to spend some
time in your humanity
and allow the
feelings to be felt
and then find a way through.
You don't, you don't deal with
it unless you go through it.
- Do you think we will, like,
do you now think we're
just in this for a while?
Like, do you sense
that sort of shift
that I'm talking about
in the world that like,
I just don't think that this
thing's going away for a while.
I don't even mean just the
specifics of the violence.
I mean, just like whatever
it is now unearthing,
I sense we're in it for a
while and then you throw
a presidential election,
which is still 13 months away.
I mean, everyone
thinks it's tomorrow
and it's 13 months away.
Like it seems to me we're
now stuck for a bit.
- Yeah, I think for a bit.
But I am very hopeful that
a change in leadership
at the top can change things.
I really, I am.
Now look, I'll be honest,
Trump brings with him such
a bag of, you know, baggage,
that will add a new
level of chaos to it all.
There's just no
question about that.
So I do think another
Republican leader
would probably bring
less, less of that chaos.
But who's kidding whom?
Like if President Trump were
in the office right now,
do any of us believe
this would've happened?
- No.
- I don't believe that.
- No, no.
- I don't think Ukraine.
- As critical as
I've been, yeah.
- No.
- Right.
- A hundred percent,
I'm with you, yeah.
- We wouldn't have
had Afghanistan.
And I realize he wanted to
withdraw from Afghanistan,
but I don't believe
for one second
that he would've done it the
way that Joe Biden did it.
- No way.
- And I think he
would've changed his
mind if he had seen any
sort of wobbling by the
Afghanis on the defense force.
But, so I don't think we
would've had Afghanistan.
I don't think we would've
had Russia and Ukraine,
and I don't think we would've
had this atrocity with Hamas.
And I do think Trump's
instability, you
know, in messaging,
in temperament when it
came to foreign policy
was a benefit to us.
You know, Rick Grinnell
tells the story
of how Angela Merkel looked
in his eyes and said like,
"I don't know what your
guy's gonna do next."
And he had to stop
himself from smiling.
You know, and bombing Soleimani
the Iranians didn't
know what to do.
They were afraid.
They were like, holy shit.
- Right.
- Bomb Soleimani.
And they were too weak
and too afraid of him
and us to do anything
in response so.
- Right, everyone said
it was gonna start-
- There were pluses
and minus of the guy.
- World War III.
Right.
- Yeah.
- Everyone said it was
gonna start World War III
and it gave us actually
three years a peace
and how many mid east peace
deals and the rest of it.
- So all of this, Dave,
is my way of saying,
I am optimistic that
we can regain stasis,
that we can regain a steadiness
that has been missing for
the past couple of years.
And I'm pretty sure that
what we're feeling right now
is akin to what our parents
were feeling in the '70's
after a couple of years
under Jimmy Carter,
that instability starts
at a very high level
and trickles down.
He's been pushing all this shit.
He opened the border,
he's allowing this myth
about boys becoming girls
and rewarding it being
taught in schools.
He's pushing the
racial essentialism
and dividing us from,
you know, K-12 and
beyond in the classroom.
He and his allies in academia,
even corporate America
and beyond are festering,
allowing to fester these lies,
which are dividing us and
making us feel disconnected.
Patriotism on the way down,
religious observance
on the way down,
and the weakness being projected
on the foreign policy front.
I really think a
lot of it starts
with the American president.
And it was a severe
mistake for Americans
to put him in office.
- Who do you think
is driving that?
Because I think you
basically said this already,
you don't believe that
Biden's really driving
the ship right now?
There's some other, you know,
everyone has their
own theory on this.
Whether it's Obama
in a Biden costume,
or it's the Obama people,
or just like some
version of something.
This does not seem like
Joe Biden is in charge.
I think someone basically
hands him notes,
he poorly reads them,
fumbles off the stage,
and then we just do
it again the next day.
Do do you have a sense of really
where this is coming from?
- I wish I knew.
I mean, my best guess is
if it's not Obama himself,
it's all of his disciples
because that's who
Joe Biden hired.
And you remember that one
appearance where Obama
came back to the White House
and how the entire
staff ignored Biden
and went right
over over to Obama.
- Unbelievable.
- I mean that
was very telling.
But I really, I wish I knew.
I don't think it is Joe Biden
and I don't think, you know,
I go back to things
like all of the rewards
that he's creating or trying
to create at the college level,
scholarships and so on,
for people who write just
the perfect BLM message.
Who major in Ibram
Xolani Kendi nonsense.
You know, he's doing
this, he's trying,
that's not Joe Biden.
He's the biggest racist, elected
the president in, I dunno,
a good 25 years.
- Well, we got our clip
for today's show. (laughs)
- (laughs) Seriously.
I mean, there's
not a week goes by
that he doesn't say
a new racist thing.
- Right.
- He's not pushing
BLM nonsense.
So who is that?
It's, I think it's the
leftover woke Obama crew.
I mean, and look at Obama,
how long did it take him?
- Yeah.
- 48 hours to even bother
to put together some anodyne
tweet on these atrocities.
Like his heart wasn't in it.
So I don't really
know the answer, Dave.
I wish I did.
You know, the closest I've
seen is that Easter Bunny,
who he really
seemed to listen to,
but I don't know who's
inside the costume.
- That's what I'm saying,
it's Obama in the
Easter Bunny costume.
- It really could be.
- Yeah, it's just, it's
because it's also like,
it's something that's,
it's why everyone's
going nuts basically.
That's what I think is that
we all know these things
that are so obvious, like
Joe Biden's not running it
and that boys actually are
boys and girls are girls.
But we're so hit
with these things.
And then all the
entire class of people
who were supposed
to say, you know,
say the truth, they
all completely failed.
And then we're
just like, oh yes,
beheading women is okay because
everything else is broken.
Why not?
Like, that's really
where I think we're at.
- This is what's so crazy.
I mean that sounds
like a laugh line.
Like you just taking something
that actually happened
and making an
absurdity out of it
that actually is happening.
- Yeah.
- Like the women, the babies,
they are being murdered.
They are being beheaded.
The elderly ladies sitting
and waiting for the bus
are being shot multiple
time by machine guns
and they're posting
the pictures online.
And then Washington Post
journalists are liking tweets
that say, what did you
think decolonization meant?
- Yeah.
- Did you think it
meant vibes, losers?
That happened?
Her name is Karen Attiah.
She writes for the
Washington Post.
I follow her, you
know why I follow her?
Because she's a BLM supporter.
She's with Kendi and DeAngelo
and all the lunatics.
But I like to get the viewpoints
of people who I disagree
with and she's one of 'em.
But she seems like
in her personal life,
kind of a nice person.
She posts pictures of her cat,
she posts pictures
of her workout.
- Oh's a cat lady.
- She expresses-
- Okay.
- She expresses insecurities
from time to time.
She, you know, and I do it
for an intentional purpose.
I like to remind myself that
my adversaries on policy
are ideologically are
not necessarily evil.
You know, they're, we disagree
very strongly, but like,
I like to like some of her
posts about her cat, Dave.
I don't have a cat,
I'm a dog person.
But I'm just saying like,
it makes me feel good.
- Yeah.
- That can still see
the humanity in this person.
It's just my own
personal private thing.
This person liked the tweet
from this lunatic activist
saying what I just said
about decolonization.
This is what it looks like.
You're a loser if you
don't understand it.
Okay, babies are
being decapitated
so you can fuck right off.
Fuck your cat and your tweet.
It's over.
Unfollow.
This is the thing that was
a bridge too far for me.
I can understand differences
on all the other stuff.
And it's not even about
exactly the Jewish thing.
It's about the humanity-
- Yeah.
- Thing.
You know, like where
is your humanity?
Like I don't get how you can
look at that beautiful group
of Israelis dancing
at the Rave for Peace.
That's what they said
they were out there for
having a good time.
It's like only a 22 year old
can do out under the open sky
and see them murdered
in the absolute,
not even the prime
of their life.
The part of the life where
everything is yet to be enjoyed
and say, ha ha, that's a win.
Yeah, you go.
I don't have anything in
common with those people.
I can't like anything
about them in my own head,
it feels like it's war.
It's on.
You're despicable.
- You know, no one ever gets
to the end of the argument.
And I think Megyn Kelly
just got to the end
of the argument and it's
so freaking refreshing.
I didn't say the F bomb
because I've dropped it
like 20 times on my show
in the last two days.
So I'm glad that you
handled it for me.
Okay, so I get you
on those people,
but what do you
think we do about,
now we have what I refer
to as the Hamas caucus.
We have AOC, we have Rashida
Tlaib, we have Ilhan Omar
and the rest of them.
What's the other one's name?
I got it.
- Cori Bush.
- Yeah, Cori Bush, et cetera.
- Yeah, thanks.
- She's such a faker.
- No, then-
- At least a couple
of those are
Palestinian American.
Cori Bush, she's like
living out of her car
and posting BLM slogans
two minutes ago.
- Yeah.
- Now she wants us to look
at her as an authority
on Israel Palestine.
Sure, sure, oh, sure, Jan.
Okay.
- But what do we do
about these people?
Look, you know how I
feel about free speech,
but I think we are
getting perilously close
where if you constantly
defend people
who are calling for genocide
and murder and beheading
babies and everything else,
and always excusing it.
And then you connect
that to the people
that are in Times Square
calling for all these things
and showing Nazi flags,
we're, I don't think
this is exactly
the neo-Nazis marching
in Skokie, Illinois
and the NAACP standing
up for them anymore.
I don't think that's
where we're at.
I think we're veering
into something else.
What do you think, what,
what do we do about this?
Do you think their allegiance
is to the constitution
that they swore to protect?
- I, I'll say this.
My first instinct is I like
that they're posting
these tweets.
It completely exposes them.
- Yeah, yeah.
- In a way that,
you know, few other,
like they've done
controversial things.
It's been pretty clear
people like Ilhan Omar are
antisemites for a long time
if you've been paying attention.
But this is just so clear.
Like it's kind of good to see
them posting these statements
and really taking
away all doubt.
It's wonderful actually.
Now we'll always
have these statements
so we can always dismiss
all of their arguments
because we understand that
these are vile people.
And anybody who is persuadable
will agree with us.
Anybody who doesn't
agree with us,
we know that they're
in the club too.
They're also antisemites.
There's absolutely
no reason to support
what they're saying right now.
So I kind of like the fact
that they have a forum
and that they're being exposed.
I find it much more
problematic at the universities
that we have hundreds
and hundreds of students
coming forward to blame
Israel for all of it.
- Yeah.
- Like that's,
that is, I mean that's
what Harvard says.
Harvard says, we raise
tomorrow's leaders
and they're not entirely wrong.
And for them to have 31
student groups blaming Israel
for all of this, and
it's not just Harvard.
Stanford, Berkeley, Yale,
Northwestern, George Washington.
I could keep going,
putting out statements.
And then in some of these cases,
the university president
says nothing in response.
We're seeing it
like at the lower,
at the high school level too.
Students coming out
who don't know jack,
trying to make
supportive statements
of Palestine, of Hamas,
they don't don't know
what they're doing.
So that actually is
problematic to me
because those people
are gonna move into positions
of power, real power.
The squad is marginalized.
For all of the bad
she did Nancy Pelosi
kept them marginalized
and that was one win
in the Pelosi file.
And they're still marginalized.
They're just such a small group.
And I just think that it's
not totally without value
to have them squawking.
So people who are sane
can point to them and say,
is that what you
wanna sign up for?
- Yeah.
- Is that what being
a democrat is?
They serve some purpose.
- Yeah, you know, you're
probably giving a much,
I would say clear-eyed account
than I'm giving of them
because I think
you're probably right.
And I have shared
some of their stuff
purely with the attention of,
okay, here they are.
All right, this is them, you
know, what are we gonna do?
We're not gonna jail 'em.
Here we go.
But I, you know, I
don't wanna get too much
into the Trump DeSantis
thing and all that,
but I do wanna ask
you a little bit
about your interview with Trump,
because it was spectacular.
I've told you that
privately and publicly,
but also because he went after
you personally years ago.
Your daughter did not
like him and now has,
I guess come around a bit.
But can you-
- She's open-minded.
- Can you, fair enough.
Well that makes her
a crazy right winger,
you know how it is.
(Megyn laughs)
But can you talk
a little bit about
how you go into that room?
Like what you're thinking
like a minute before knowing,
I just know you,
you want challenge on the
right things and you did,
but you also don't want
it to be the last time
you ever sit down with him.
And there's always that
weird moment with him
where it could go
in either direction.
Could you just talk a,
just like your philosophy more
than about like the specifics
of the politics?
- Well, I knew going in there
before I even arrived
at Bedminster,
his golf club in New
Jersey where he was,
that it would probably
one, be one and done.
That if I were gonna do
my duty as a journalist,
it was gonna be one and done.
Because he just doesn't
allow ongoing access
unless you kiss his ass.
You know, that's kind of
the way it is with Trump.
And that's fine.
He can set the terms, you know,
like it's kind of,
that's how it is, okay.
You go in knowing that.
So my goal was not to please
Trump because to please Trump,
I would've had to abandon
my journalistic duty.
But my goal was also not,
I'm gonna kill Trump.
I'm gonna emerge
with Trump's jugular.
You know, this is it
since it's one and done.
I'm gonna crush him.
I'm gonna unleash all my A game
and you know, try
to take him out.
No, that wasn't it either.
I wanted to do like a lively,
interesting, challenging,
but also informative
interview with him,
one that would have
something for everybody.
So I felt when it was
over that I did, you know,
there was stuff that
MAGA really liked.
His reflections on whether
this is worth it, you know,
like what he could be
doing instead of this.
His reflections
about his family, his
thoughts on Joe Biden,
the difference between age
and competence and all that.
Stuff that would be there for,
you know, people like you who
are are gonna vote Republican
probably, but don't want Trump.
- Yeah.
- You know Trump's
weakness on that front.
- Look he's the nominee
I'm voting for him, obviously.
I mean, it goes
without question.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- And then, you know,
stuff, not for the liberals,
but stuff that
would be important
to any objective interview.
Like his legal
troubles, you know?
And that was one of my
irritants as a journalist
is just I haven't seen
anybody done do a good job
of challenging him on
the legal troubles.
And it's really been bothering
me and I knew I had to do it
and I knew he wouldn't like it.
And sure enough, I was right.
- What was the part,
there were a couple moments
in there that went viral
'cause you did end up, again,
not because you were
trying to get him,
but you did get him
on a couple things.
I mean, the gender one you
asked the most basic question,
are there differences
between boys and girls?
And he like fumbled
for good five seconds
and then offered this
like odd sort of,
I guess so answer if a
woman could give birth,
which obviously does
not decide gender
because there are obviously
women who cannot give birth.
Like was that the
weirdest one for you
or was there something else?
Was it more on the
legal stuff or on the.
- I was surprised
that he didn't have,
did not have a better answer
for can a man become a woman?
Sometimes the simplest questions
are the hardest ones, you know?
And he definitely got
caught on that one,
which wasn't a trick
question, you know?
I did not intend for it
to be a trick question.
The legal stuff, I really
wanted to press him a little
because he continues
to just say,
I am covered by the
Presidential Records Act.
I'm covered, I'm
covered, I'm covered.
And I just, I, you
know, as a lawyer,
I understand exactly
the whole argument,
the law and where
the pitfalls are.
And he, you could
see when I had him,
to Trump's credit, he was smart.
He knew when I had
him and he'd go to,
I'm not gonna answer that.
So he is getting smarter about
not giving too much ammo,
you know, to reporters or
by extension prosecutors
in these interviews.
He's smart.
I mean, Trump is
definitely very smart.
So I knew he wasn't
gonna like that stuff,
but he needed to be
asked those questions.
And I would say the one that
sort of I was laughing about
most after it was
over was his obsession
with my debate
question from 2015.
(Dave laughs)
Still, still.
Get over it.
It's been eight years, move on.
He can't.
- I mean, your daughter
has moved on, so it's time,
it's time to move on.
What would you make
of, of the argument?
'Cause you know, there
was a clip when I,
I think you were on my
show maybe a year ago
when we were talking about
the Trump DeSantis thing
that seemed like it
was gonna shake out
and it went really viral
because you basically were like,
look, it's Trump because
nobody can defeat that monster.
And I basically said,
you might be right.
I still think you
might be right.
But it seems to
me that right now,
at this moment for having
everything we just talked about,
we need someone like,
just like hyper competent
and clear and no BS
that can deliver the
message without the bullshit
and all of that stuff.
And it's very obvious to me,
there's a guy that can do that.
You did interview him
by the way too DeSantis.
It took a little while and
you were critical of him
beforehand and he,
and he did it as well.
Do you think enough people
care about competency anymore?
And maybe that's
part of everything
that we've discussed here
in terms of the collapse
of all this stuff
that really we kind of just
do want the reality show
and not the competent one.
So we'll get exactly
what we deserve.
- I don't think competency
is the driving factor,
but I see the calculation
a little differently.
I think that what we
need is the person
who can get elected, right?
Like if you want Joe
Biden out, and I do,
I've been open about it
for the reasons I stated,
you have to go with whoever
is most likely to do that.
And I know that Nikki Haley's
supporters think it's her
and Ron DeSantis
supporters think it's him.
But my calculation is somebody
who would take any
of those guys or gals
is you gotta get the one
who can bring together
the biggest coalition.
And the Trump coalition
is never leaving Trump.
They're just not
going to leave him.
So I think the rest
of the coalition
is probably going to
migrate over to them
because they're immovable.
I just see that
as their reality.
So eventually the rest,
they're just gonna have to bend
to the Trump coalition's will,
because the Trump
voters are not gettable,
that some 25 to 35%.
Depending on, you
know, who you believe.
They're just never gonna move.
And the Republicans need to win.
So if they wanna win,
I even think like, you know,
the establishment Republicans
sort of the Reagan library
or Republicans, the Chamber of
Commerce, like, they're like,
we can't stand that
we're in this position.
We don't want Trump.
And then the only thing we
hate more than Trump is Biden.
- Yeah.
- So these guys
on their motorcycles
and in their trucks
are gonna drag us on over there
and we're gonna have to vote
for the orange man again.
And my position on the outside
where I am just
watching it all is,
okay, I guess we're
gonna go this way again.
It's fine as long as we don't
stay on the path we're on.
- Yeah.
- Which I see is
the most deadly
destructive possible path.
- You know, look, it's obvious.
I, I don't hide anything here.
I obviously think that DeSantis
would be the best chief
executive to get us out of this.
And you know, I just saw him
this morning at a synagogue
in Miami and it's like
the guy speaks, you know,
he's not the most
entertaining speaker,
but he speaks from the heart
with no notes and with clarity
and knows history and
all of those things.
I was like that guy,
as I'm watching him,
that guy should
be the president.
But if at the end of this,
Trump is the president and
DeSantis is my governor,
all right.
Like, it would be okay with me.
You know what I mean?
Like, it, it would be okay.
But, you know, you mentioned
the Reagan library.
I was there, what was it,
10 days ago or so
for that debate.
It was basically a shit
show from top to bottom
from the moderators.
- Yeah.
- And I consider Dana a friend.
I'm sure you know her
from your Fox days like.
But just like the entire thing
felt like it was from 1994,
if the Simpsons
had done a parody
of what a Republican
debate would be, right?
Like, did you watch it
thinking man, none of this man,
like you gimme Megyn
Kelly, and Rubin
and throw in Michael
Malice or whoever you want
like as the moderators,
and people might've
learned something,
including the
people on the stage.
Like is that machinery
just completely broken
and calcified and and done
but they just won't throw in?
- It was that night?
- Yeah.
I wouldn't say it's,
it's done as a mechanism.
I think it could still work,
but it didn't that night.
I mean, there were so many
things that were wrong.
Moderators had no control.
It's not to say that it's easy,
but you should at least try.
You're not there to serve
the presidential candidates.
You're there to
serve the audience.
You're the traffic cop.
Do it, do it.
Sorry, you may
not like your job.
You may think you, you
might seem a little rude,
but that's part
of the art of it,
is sort of trying to
thread that needle
between being respectful
of the audience at home
and making sure
that the candidates
can be heard and
not being, you know,
too overbearing and acting like,
you know, a bully
who everybody hates.
I don't think any of
them had ever hosted
a presidential debate
before and it showed.
The woman from Univision-
- Yeah.
- Was an embarrassment.
- And, and it was Fox.
Like, I don't know
why Fox agreed to
partner with Univision.
I really don't.
It was people are
online saying, oh no,
they didn't have any
choice, it was the RNC.
That's not true.
I'm here to tell you
that's not how it works.
- Oh, interesting.
- Fox 100% could have said
we're not gonna
partner with them.
- Hmm.
- Who do you think
was paying for that debate?
You think it was Univision?
It wasn't.
It was Fox News, which has
more money than everybody.
And so it was Fox News's money,
and I'm sure Univision paid
some small paltry amount
to sort of partner on it.
And it was, would've
been up to Fox
as the big money
maker payer to say,
we don't want them.
We want somebody else. There's
a million plays you could do,
the Wall Street Journal like
they did on debate number one.
There's a lot of
conservative outlets
you could partner,
a Daily Caller.
What have you.
Probably wouldn't
'cause it's Tucker,
Whatever.
There's a lot.
- Right.
- They chose them and then
they let this woman run wild
and she ruined their debate.
That lunatic ruined
their debate.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And by the way, you know,
it's like Dana and Stewart
like better than
the Univision lady,
but I'll just leave it at that.
And that question about
like the survivor,
it was beneath the
dig the dignity
of the debate, of the
candidates, of the anchors.
I don't understand
how it didn't wind up
in the editing room floor.
And I'll tell you,
it's like both of these debates
that we've watched so far
have made me say the same thing,
which is, forgive me,
'cause it's, it's a
little self-aggrandizing.
But I miss Brett, Chris
Wallace and yours truly.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Sitting down together
and coming up with
the toughest best,
but most on point debate
questions we could.
And the way we used to do
it was we would split it up
into the three, the
amongst the three of us,
we would choose our subjects
'cause we all had our favorites.
You know, like Brett always
liked foreign policy.
I always loved social issues.
Wallace always liked
economic issues.
So we never really fought
over who's gonna do what.
And you had sort of
have your first choice
and then you divide
the second choice.
Anyway, it always worked out.
And you go back to
your respective dens
and you'd work out the
toughest questions you could.
And the brain room at Fox
would give you all the
background information
you needed on your favorite
issues in your candidates.
And then you'd meet and you'd
come up with, here's what I,
here's my list, here's
where I've gone.
And the other two would just
murder board your questions.
Not tight enough, too weak,
too easy, too ba ba, too nasty,
too, not nasty enough.
And, and then the debate team,
Bill, Sam and Chris Stirewalt
those are dirty names now
amongst some of the
hardcore MAGA crew,
because they were
behind the Arizona call.
- Oh.
- Decent, honest journalist,
Fox never should have
gotten rid of them.
Anyway they challenge
you even more.
They tighten it up
even even tougher.
And so by the time
you got out there,
you had these gleaming, sharp,
beautiful questions
that had come
from your heart and your brain,
but it had been
polished by a whole team
of people you respected.
And when I asked my question,
or Chris asked his question,
or Brett asked his question,
the three of us would
be beaming with pride
because we all had a hand in
it in some way, shape, or form.
And we all trusted the
others to not back down
and to be strong and be a good
representative of Fox News
and of the audience watching.
And all I can tell you is
I've been sorely missing
that whole thing.
- How many of those did you do?
- Five.
- Yeah man, give
it to Megyn Kelly.
I'll send a letter to somebody.
I don't know that anyone's
responding to my letters.
Let me ask you something
else that I think,
it just popped in my head as
you were saying something.
This is probably more what
I would ask you offline,
but we're on camera, why not?
Do you, when you have
all these relationships
with these people,
the politicians
and then the other pundits
and the talking heads
and all of that, do you find
at times it can be tough?
'Cause I, this is just
personally what I've found now
is that because I'm
friendly at least
with so many of these
people and know them
and have played
basketball with them
or had them over for
dinner or whatever,
sometimes there's this
piece of me where I want
to not criticize someone
as much as I should,
or I at least have to think
about it in a different way.
Or you don't wanna say something
about a certain politician
because then they
won't do your show.
Like how do you
balance all of that?
Because you've been on both
sides of this mainstream
and now this side, you've
interviewed everybody.
You basically know everybody.
I've never heard of anyone
say a bad word about you
except maybe some people at NBC.
So like, you know, like how
do you balance all of that
and still maintain integrity?
- I have very few friends.
You're on a very
short list, my friend.
- I'm on the short list.
- You didn't realize.
- Oh, that's nice.
- You didn't realize
how valuable this-
- Wow.
- This friendship was to me.
No, I have a very short list.
I don't fraternize with them.
If they're politicians, I
don't fraternize with them.
You know, it's, I'll
give you one example,
I'll give you two examples.
Vivek Ramaswamy first
came into my life
as somebody who knew Jed
Rubenfeld of Yale Law School,
who's a brilliant professor
and they'd been
co-writing pieces
for the Wall Street Journal
editorial page or op-eds
and on legal issues.
And I was like, oh, these
are good legal issues.
They were getting at sort of
the erosion of free speech.
And I know Jed a bit,
he's married to Amy
Chua at Tiger Mom.
- Oh, oh, right, right.
- Anyway.
- Of course yeah.
I've had her on.
- So I knew them a little.
And so I got to know Vivek
and I started to read books.
I started reading his books
and he'd asked me for comment,
whatever, I know I'm a bit.
Like him.
Fine.
I would fraternize with Vivek.
Then he decided
to run for office.
It's done.
It's off.
We're not friends.
Sorry, we're adversarial.
That's the only way I
can do my job, honestly.
You, it's fine, I'm not
like your enemy now.
- Yeah.
- But I'm gonna hit you.
I'm gonna hit you repeatedly
if you do dumb things
or things I think are dumb
or worthy of challenge.
Not to say I'm the
ultimate arbiter,
but I am of my show.
And it can't be that
friendly anymore.
It just can't be.
So you kind of know, hmm,
he's running for office.
This is not the end of
our personal friendship,
but it's definitely gonna
be on pause for a long time.
And then my second
example is Donald Trump,
when he was a celebrity
and, you know, on TV,
he used to come on Fox, he
was great. He always raided.
He was fun to talk to.
He invited me to a couple
of these "Celebrity Apprentice"
things, which I went to.
He was always very gregarious,
you know, he'd walk in,
he'd give you the big hug
and kiss and like, ah.
It was tough not to like Trump.
And then he decided
to run for president
and he invited me to
go down to Mar-a-Lago.
you've gotta see it.
It's so beautiful. Sent me
all these pictures of it.
I was like, hell no, I'm
not going to Mar-a-Lago,
the guy is running
for president.
Guess what?
A lot of other journalists
did not make the same choice.
Then he found out that I
was going on a girls trip
and we were gonna stay at Trump,
I know one of his hotels,
and he tried to pay for it.
He reached out to say,
where are you staying?
- Ooh.
- I'll take care of it.
Oh, very nice, right?
- Ooh yeah.
- In quotes. It's not nice.
And I said, absolutely not.
Thank you very much Mr. Trump,
we'll pay for our own hotel.
And I said to
Abby, my assistant,
make sure you hold
onto the records.
You know, like they,
this is what
politicians try to do
and humans try to do it too.
It's one thing for
Donald Trump's celebrity
to try to woo me
over to liking him.
That's less fraught.
But politician Donald Trump
has to receive a hard no
in response to all
those overtures.
And Dave, that night,
I went on to the debate
stage August 6th, 2015
and asked him that
very hard question.
There were lots
of hard questions,
just that one that
everybody remembers.
You know, what I
had behind my notes,
in addition to my outline
and my fact checks,
which are 10 deep,
and I was ready to back
up everything I asked.
I had the receipts from
that Trump hotel visit
and my rejection of his
invitation to go to Mar-a-Lago.
- Ooh.
- Because-
- You were ready.
- I didn't want anybody
using that against me.
Same as I'll have to do
it to Vivek Ramaswamy
if he ever tries to
say you did, you know?
Like it's just, it
gets very complicated
when you have to cover
them objectively.
So I think, you know, you
either have to choose,
or you have to just be
very open about your bias.
You know, like, I know
you're a DeSantis guy,
you've been open about that,
so I think you're okay there.
But if you have too many
of those with politicians,
it can get dicey quickly.
- Yeah.
And for sure, you know, for
just from, for my perspective,
like the politician version,
I don't have that much of it.
You know, I played
basketball with Ted Cruz
or I played video
games with him.
We're like some of that stuff,
but we're not like
friends like that.
I think for me, it's more
like the pundit class
where I see guys that
are like kind of doing
what we do and then they kind of
go completely off the deep
end and I'm like, ugh,
do I have to call you out?
It's more that I
think for me than the-
- Yes, well you have, and
the answer is yes, you do.
You you have to.
- You do. No, I do.
And like you, I have my,
my short friend list so.
- I've gotta tell you one other.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So couple years
back, there's this guy,
his name is Carlos Watson,
he invites me to go
on his YouTube show.
I never heard of Carlos Watson.
I'm like, who is he?
Abby's like, I don't know, but
you're sandwiched in between,
it was like LeBron
James and Bill Gates.
So I'm like, who is this guy?
Like, he's got access
to some very big names
and I don't remember
what the forum was on,
but it was on a big day.
It was like election night.
And so I'm like,
okay, I'll do it.
She's like, he's got
all these followers.
His show's very successful.
Okay so I did it.
Carlos was a perfect
gentleman, very nice guy,
solid interviewer.
Had a good time.
Then I went on a couple
more times, fine.
Eventually I'm
like, you know what?
I launched my show, I'm
like, I'll have him on.
Had him on very nice.
Kind of cagey about like
what his background was.
He didn't wanna
talk about his life,
but that's fine.
Some people are like that.
Then he wanted me to
go to his Ozy Fest.
It was like a, you know,
like one of those media
things like Jordan has,
you know, everybody goes.
Okay.
I'm like, I don't know.
Then I see the list
of everybody's going.
It's like all these amazing
names, people I respect,
people I know.
I'm like, all right, you
know, I'll look into it.
And the next thing I see,
Carlos and Ozy Media are
under SEC investigation
for impersonating a YouTube CEO,
the officer, the
chief executive, or
COO of the company,
as Goldman Sachs was
trying to figure out
whether it was going to give
Ozy another business loan
and wanted to kick the tires
and see if those YouTube
numbers were real.
Well, instead of connecting
them with the actual YouTube,
his CFO faked being
the YouTube executive,
lied about their numbers.
The whole thing
came crashing down.
It was a house of cards
that was all made up.
The YouTube numbers were fake.
Carlos pretty soon
thereafter was under arrest.
The CFO was under arrest.
Ozy Fest was off.
And I'm thinking to myself,
it don't become chummy
with any of these people.
And I went out on
the air and I'm like,
I've got something to tell
you members of my audience,
this guy who we had
on not too long ago
and celebrated his
independent entrepreneurship,
he's a fraud according to the
government and several others.
Anyway, it's just the
whole business is fraught.
And if you become
friends with me,
there's a 90% chance you're
gonna wind up being a fraudster
'cause that's happened to me
over and over, Dave Rubin.
- Excuse me, Megyn
Kelly, we are friends.
We have shared
tequila many times,
and I am not a fraud.
And you are not a,
you, you actually,
I know I can say nice things
about you all the time,
but when people
always ask me, Dave,
who do you watch to make
any sense to any of this?
It's like, it's basically you.
It's you and Jordan for me.
- And-
- Thank you.
- I thank you for
doing this as always.
And are you gonna come to,
why don't you come down to
Miami for the next debate?
We can have tequila and you
can yell at the the moderators.
What do you think?
- Oh, sure.
Oh, I'd love to reconnect
with my old pals from NBC.
I'll do it if you and I can
sit behind them with tomatoes.
- Yes, that can be arranged.
- Bitter party of one, no two.
- We're more of an orange state.
We can throw some
oranges at 'em.
- It's done.
- If you're looking for
more uncensored opinions
from today's thought leaders,
check out our media playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.